sur la totalité du réseau routier
français
la vitesse sera limitée à 100 km à
l'heure étant entendu que les sections
des routes nationales où la vitesse est
déjà limitée à 110 kilomètres à l'heure
resteront à cette vitesse de 110
kilomètres à l'heure et que d'autres
sections à mesure de leurs améliorations
pourront être portés à cette même
vitesse de 110 à l'heure avant que vous
ne preniez la route avec votre ceinture
de sécurité
obligatoirement bouclé à partir de
dimanche
voici une illustration de ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire et des sanctions qui vous
guette désormais vous devez respecter
les stops
même s'il n'ya apparemment personne si
vous grillé le stop vous risquez un à
quatre mois de suspension du permis de
conduire et une forte amende doublée en
troisième position en franchissant en
plus une ligne continue
ça équivaut au retrait systématique du
permis pendant six mois si vous n'êtes
pas en état d'ébriété et si vous n'avez
pas provoqué d'accident
sinon la suspension peut aller jusqu'à
30 mois le franchissement d'un feu rouge
ou le refus d'obtempérer aux sommations
d'un gendarme ou d'un policier
suspension du permis de 20 à 20 mois
plus la mangue
n'oubliez pas que les routes sans
panneaux sont toutes limitées à 100
lever le pied
si votre aiguille a tendance à
s'orienter vers la droite pour les
routes à panneaux rien changer il suffit
de respecter ces panneaux les gendarmes
et les crs seront d'ailleurs très
nombreux sur les routes pour les grands
départs et ils auront leur radar les
excès de vitesse peuvent provoquer le
retrait du permis pour quatre mois sur
les routes limitées à 100 beaucoup
d'automobilistes ne savent pas comment
ils doivent se comporter pour dépasser
un véhicule roulant à 90 kilomètres à
l'heure un camion par exemple s'il
dépasse le sang risque-t-il d'être en
infraction sera admis lorsqu'il s'agira
des passes et des véhicules isolé
roulant en dessous de la vitesse limite
bien entendu il faut pas que cette
tolérance donne lieu à des abus c'est à
dire que on en profite pour doubler des
fils continue de véhicules ou les
véhicules qui roulent déjà à la vitesse
de 100 km heure
mais cette mesure de tolérance devraient
faciliter des choses on pourra rouler à
combien de temps à plus de 100
kilomètres à l'heure
le temps de doubler le véhicule et se
rabattent c'est à dire quelque chose
assez bref pour faciliter la fluidité et
la sécurité du trafic
ne pensez-vous pas que
de fait d'imposer 100 kilomètres à
l'heure uniformément risque de créer de
longues files de voitures qui ne sera
pas possible de doubler
écoutez je ne pense pas il faut bien
voir que les files de voitures résulte
essentiellement des grands départs en
week-end des grands départs pour les
vacances et qu'elles se produisent tous
les ans qu'il y ait ou qu'il n'y ait pas
limitations de vitesse je prends
contraire que la mesure de tolérance qui
était admise pour le dépassement devrait
éviter ces longues files que l'on craint
et qui ne sont pas en fait une
conséquence de la limitation de vitesse
vous savez tout de même que certains
camions roulent déjà à 100 kilomètres à
l'heure
alors est ce qu'il sera possible de les
doubler
aucun camion n'a le droit de rouler à
100 km heure avec les poids lourds font
l'objet limitation particulière à 80 km
heure pour la plupart d'entre eux donc
je pense que le problème est d'abord que
ces points nous respectent les
limitations de vitesse et à ce moment là
les dépassements devraient pouvoir
s'effectuer sans trop difficile de toute
manière c'est une mesure nouvelle
il faut voir ce qu'elle donne je pense
que dans trois mois on pourra tirer les
premières conclusions
j'espère que sur le plan des accidents
ce seront des conclusions positives
ce n'est plus un secret pour personne la
plupart des routes en france sont
limitées en voici un exemple en vache
qui est moins évident c'est le cas que
les automobilistes font de cette
limitation de vie
alors que nous en rendre compte que nous
sommes livrés à une expérience fort
simple nous avons nous mêmes à bord
d'une automobile respecter cette
limitation de vitesse vous allez voir
que les autres automobilistes n'ont pas
fait tout comme nous
sur cette portion d'autoroute où la
vitesse est limitée à 80 kilomètres
heure en raison de travaux la plupart
des automobiles nous doublent à plus de
100 km
il semble que le seul remède contre
l'excès de vitesse soit la peur wazi
ancestrale du gendarme pour peu que sa
silhouette se profile à l'horizon les
stops des voitures salut
[Applaudissements]
comme quoi l'on ne doit pas trop faire
confiance au sens de la responsabilité
du conducteur
il y a pourtant au moins deux raisons
indiscutable de respecter la limitation
de vitesse les vitesses que l'on indique
c'est parfait comme ça ça correspondait
chose de précis ça correspond un rayon
de courbure ça correspond à une distance
de civilisation ça correspond à la
longueur d'une bande jaune par exemple
des fêtes vous reconnais que ça nous
échappons jeudi mais enfin bon blanc
prenaient plus vite
non c'est bien fait alors au fond si
vous allez au delà et bien votre vitesse
ne correspond plus aux distances prévu
vous allez vous trouver trop vite sur
une bande continue
vous avez vous trouvé trop vite d'un
croisement vous aider à booster disant
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font on n'est pas
preneurs saint-aubin non c'est parce que
votre vitesse ne correspond pas il faut
vraiment respecté ce qui est fait comme
dans l'aviation on à des vitesses proche
de terry sage comme ma le chemin de fer
qu'en cessant ses 140 tvo le faire sur
l'aspect inverse aussi un petit peu sur
certaines routes on voit des panneaux
par exemple limitation à 120 les gens
croient qu'ils peuvent rouler à 120
alors on n'a jamais dit ça on a dit que
c'est la vitesse maxi est dépassé mais
s'il ya du brouillard de la grêle
s'il ya là que je vais te fatiguer pour
les -10 c'est la vitesse maxi vouloir se
met alors à cette époque de retour de
vacances là alors qu'il commence à
rouler dur moi j'ai une raisons de
respect de la vitesse qui est toute bête
qui est très simple c'est encore
actuellement le meilleur moyen de garder
permis de conduire parce que y'a trêve
un contrôle est vraiment sévère ou pas
que ça vire sévère ça veut dire que la
piste nationale et la gendarmerie font
des contrôles indiscutable avec des
cinémomètres et que moi je sais que ça
se multiplient et que c'est très très
embêtant c'est embêtant est arrêté mais
sans btan de payer entre 100 et 300
francs de recevoir voir un avertissement
avoir un petit retrait c'est embêtant de
rentrer chez soi en cédant au top sans
permis de conduire lors c'est une raison
bien bien bête mais moi je dis qu'il
faut respecter la limitation de vitesse
les limites à la limitation en ville en
particulier
[Musique]